welcome to this video playing against
French defense again of course French
defense place the broad opening up
always very red in the video title this
name French defense okay um yeah that's
not very ambitious yeah with d3 but
capturing is probably not really doing
that much so there any way to be a
little bit more ambitious here maybe
yeah nine to six or something occupying
a little bit more the center I never
mind that he will probably that he can
take our queen Texas is totally fine the
Queen getting a centralized without
being subject to a text yeah what about
yeah
I take now Queen you wanna it's not
really leading to anything the Queen
trade a g'nite f6c has a fire and the
night is not having that red squares
maybe here maybe the set up with 97 that
looks that looks quite um quite solid
young maybe b6 bishop a six that's okay
I also keep an eye over the f5 square
very often f4 f5 is the key attacking
move that trees to see one of the ship
like Queenie one tweenage form f5 bishop
86 this kind of thing and very often
it's good to have the night only seven
that it is an additional guarding piece
for f5 so that you can more reliably
take it that's interesting i was
thinking about this move and i wasn't
sure what to do maybe d FOIA well be six
looks totally normal but also d4 comes
into consideration I was thinking he
just plays Bishop f2 we have C takes
Knight takes is definitely okay for me I
guess but he can go to f2 but this
should be a good structure yes after d4
if he goes to have to he will not be
able to move his night easily see for he
can play okay and I can take working its
first things first yes see for him maybe
I should have prevented this I don't
know it's not oh he's blundering at for
him or not he has this counter check on
c 1 c 5 where I still have to take also
night f5 that's actually an interesting
question I can go be 6 cm and play for
Knight a5 e3 anyway
yeah why not let's just fortify this
then those weaknesses don't go away and
therefore is not easily covered I mean
you can go Queen d2 or something but
it's not leading to to anything great
and I always have 95 I can even play
Knight f5 and just put it only 34 pawn
sacrifice it will open up everything the
bishop on g7 will come to life and i
will put the second bishop ok stop
before just mechanically stopping this
move yeah basically idea of rook a oh
yeah this is what I was hoping for I'll
just stick it in in only three and he
can take the pawn that this is fantastic
now with the night here fantastic pieces
Bishop on b7 and on g7 and I'm even
threatening rook takes a forum for for
direct things ok putting it here but if
I go Queen c7 how do you actually
maintain the night down can also take
but
Bishop here Teague's check green d4
check that's definitely good but I
really don't see what he's playing
against queens is seven there's really
no good more
this even rook takes f4 in the mix
rucca voice I mean I come on I just do
that not arguing any longer just do that
I mean this is just so great yeah with
those bishops it should be fantastic
ready so if i take here 1g three I can
also take e to 92 that looks very nice
9292 bishop page to check king f2 but
then I don't see a win and I can also
take here and Quincy 6 which is also
very nice Quincy 6 immediately it's got
94 that's not so good yeah it's all good
yeah i can hg i can take our need to
with check Queenie took Queen g3
Winningham this is this is chat much
simpler than anything else of course
just this he has to play a king move now
and then I just go back to the form with
the fantastic position night and Bishop
hatch is fantastic again still
threatening Luke evade king he one night
see to us can embarrassing hi morning
check check here we go but this was
indefensible white resigns yeah this was
this was really a case where this g
forms I was just hoping that something
like this is coming because well night
to e3 is in the in the position anyway
but after g4 is just like opening up the
whole King side and here black is good
anyway because i have this ideas like
'if I've bishop age 6 this is just a big
weakness but after G form
this is really really problematic and
probably I had various ideas him here I
can also take it yeah calm points out
night c2 which is very good yeah okay I
didn't think about this I was thinking
about this move and thought okay this is
probably good but it it's not this is
not as convincing him he has this nice
blockading night I think what I played
is certainly not bad but this is
definitely best yeah yeah with Queen D
for now being extra strong has to move
the Queen check then I can do this yes
and here yeah this is strong now rook f8
is a very very substantial threat and
the night is controlling the two squares
weather might want to go to so something
like that is going to happen yeah that's
very nice but it's it's something that
it's difficult to calculate yeah the
double attack now and I mean when you
see it in analysis given by the engine
it looks fantastic but it's not totally
simple to see in the game with us this
is keeping the pressure on simply
computer now gives Bishop f3 and black
is just one pawn up who still looks very
efficient this was probably losing her
okay the best move and that's great now
the best move according to the engine is
g5 with an evaluation of minus eight
yeah well black is threatening to take
on f4 and check on e5 here and it's very
difficult you could do anything about it
but look ere for I believe should be
good as well I am it's not minus eight
but minus minus 2 or something okay
adhere here I'm definitely winning it
took me a while to figure this out night
so 2 nite c 2 is also strong for Bishop
g4 but this is just good yeah because I
can take chair I was also thinking about
this move but ultimately when I saw that
you can just take and he cannot
recapture this is just good and now you
Black is just overwhelming a night and
bishop in this wide open position it
already stumbled into the fork but it's
it's it's totally lost anyway here for
example that Knight f3 will will do the
job and just check win tons of material
maybe there's something better but just
winning the material yes is enough you
you keep the initiative and the meeting
attack alright thanks for watching